يتذكر احمد بوضوح اللحظات الاولى للكارثه
يدلنا على المكان الذي انتشل من تحت ركامه
فحتى قبل ايام قليله كان هذا منزله
الرابعه وعشرين دقيقه بدات الارض تهتز
بعدها بدقائق انهار المبنى لا تذكر الوقت
بالتحديد وكنت خائفا جدا
يتجمع الاقرباء قرب المبنى المنهار اثر
البقاء في مكان قريب فلم يحن موعد الرحيل
بعد
منازل بعضهم قائمه لا يعودون اليها خوفا
من سقوطها يسترقون لحظات راحه لا تمح واثق
لا محل بهم
استبدل احمد منزله بخيمه كحال الاف
العائلات ليس امامهم من خيار اخر
الوضع صعب جدا الخيمه ليست منزلا لم نعد
نشعر بدفئ منازلنا
ويخطف الاطفال وقتا مستقطعا من الماساه
التي دفعتهم الى قسوه الحياه مبكرا
فهكذا تبدو مدينتهم ملئها الدمار خيام
بيضاء تخبرنا عن حجم المعاناه
تصل الاغاثه والمساعدات الى مواقع الايواء
المتعدده في المدينه لتلبيه احتياجات
ضروريه وعاجله
تتوفر للعائلات وجبه ساخنه وهذا امر نقوم
به في مطبخ مجهز نحرص دوما على وجود
طبيبين في المكان لضمان رعايه صحيه
للعائلات وبالطبع تستمر المساعدات بالتدفق
هنا يلملمون اشلاء حياتهم او يحاولون
الياس لم يتسلل الى قلوبهم يقولون لنا
يؤمنون بانهم سينهضون من جديد
فدون ايمان كهذا تصبح الواقع قادما
بين عائلات فقدت الماوى واخرى تنتظر مصير
منازلها باتت هذه المخيمات ملاذا للالاف
السلطات تشدد على ضروره عدم العوده الى
المنازل لحين التحقق من سلامه المباني
التي لم يطالها الدمار والضرر سلام خضر
الجزيره